The Inventor of the PEZ
As a teenager, the inventor of the PEZ confectionery
created one of the world’s first ready-made
cake mixes, popularly selling it throughout
the Austro-Hungarian Empire.
The teenager was Eduard Haas III.
Haas III’s grandfather, Eduard Haas I, was
a doctor who invented a type of “light”
baking powder which he advocated over yeast
in recipes as he felt it was easier on people’s
digestive systems.
As a teen, Haas III began selling and promoting
his grandfather’s baking powder at his father’s
wholesale grocery store.
While the packets of baking powder Haas III
sold came with a recipe book and suggestions
on how much to use as a substitute for yeast
in recipes, Haas III got the bright idea one
day to save people the trouble of having to
measure out all the ingredients for Gugelhupf
cakes, a type of torus shaped Bundt cake made
with raisins and almonds embedded in the cake.
Thus, in 1914, he started putting together
packets of the necessary ingredients for Gugelhupf
cake all mixed together, called “Hasin,
the Ready-Made Health Sponge Cake Mix”.
About four years later, the now 20 year old
Haas III began creating a line of other products
including Haas Pudding Powder, Vanillin Sugar,
and a gelling aid called Quittin, which also
all sold quite well.
Now with his baking business booming, Haas
III decided to branch out and helped develop
a method of cold pressing peppermint into
small “peppermint bonbon” bricks.
He distributed these to various friends and
colleagues to get feedback on the peppermint
candies and they were received well, so he
went forward with selling “Pfefferminze”
or “PEZ” to the public in small tins.
Fast forward to the 1940s where Haas III decided
to start marketing PEZ as a substitute for
cigarettes, specifically targeting people
who were trying to quit smoking.
(Haas III was a staunch anti-smoking advocate).
He reasoned that people who were trying to
quit smoking would have the habit of needing
to put something in their mouths, so hoped
they’d use his confectionery bricks.
His slogan for this was, “Smoking prohibited,
PEZing allowed”
Towards this end, in 1947 Haas III decided
that instead of putting PEZ in tins, as he
had before, they should be put in a device
that would look like a cigarette lighter,
which would also make it easy to share PEZ
with others in a hygienic fashion.
Haas III then enlisted the aid of Oscar Uxa
to create this new dispenser, called a “PEZ
box”, or on the patent a “Pocket Article
Dispensing Container”, which sold very well
over the next few years.
Up to this point, PEZ was marketed solely
at adults, including advertising with risqué
“PEZ girls”.
They didn’t begin marketing to children
until the 1950s when Haas III and co. were
trying to sell PEZ in the U.S., without much
success.
At the urging of Curtis Allina, VP in charge
of U.S. operations, they switched gears and
began targeting children in the United States,
including creating fruit flavored bricks,
instead of just peppermint PEZ, and beginning
to create character based PEZ dispensers,
which were initially full body molds, rather
than just heads on a uniform box base as they
are today.
These character based PEZ dispensers were
a huge hit and helped make PEZ a relatively
popular confectionary, even to this day.
Bonus Facts:
• While Haas III tried to use peppermint
(and the menthol in it) to help people stop
smoking, the cigarette industry went the other
way with that, using it to get people to smoke
more.
Specifically, menthol works fairly well as
a short term reliever for sore throats and
other minor mouth, nose, and throat irritations.
Thus, adding menthol to cigarettes helps sooth
the smoker’s irritated throats, allowing
for more smoking without immediate added discomfort.
• On that note, menthol also works well
to help sooth certain cold and flu symptoms.
It also has been shown to help relieve bloating
and pain from menstrual cramps.
Menthol also works well in conjunction with
aloe as a good sunburn treatment.
The cooling sensation it provides helps ease
the pain.
Besides that, Menthol works decently as a
low level pesticide and as a good mosquito
repellant.
Not only will it repel mosquitoes, but mint
oil also will kill them if they come in close
contact with it.